JENNY MURPHY: At Google I/O two
weeks ago, we had a lot of
important, exciting stuff happen
then, so we have a lot
of cool stuff to discuss.
And I guess we'll start
with introductions.
So joining me here in the new
Google+ platform office at our
studios, we have--
WOLFF DOBSON: Google Office
Hours Worldwide.
JENNY MURPHY: Worldwide.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
Worldwide Studios.
I'm Wolff Dobson.
I'm a developer programs
engineer.
I'm on Google+, mostly
on Hangouts.
JENNY MURPHY: I'm Jenny Murphy,
developer programs
engineer on Google+, and I focus
mostly on Publisher and
the new Google+ History API.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hi.
I'm Timothy, also developer
advocate, or I guess, the only
developer advocate
at the table--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I
was going to say.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --working
on Google+.
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And can I just
say I'm so excited to be here?
JENNY MURPHY: It's good to
have you here, Timothy.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: This is fun!
Haven't done one of these.
Look, we're on TV.
Hi, TV.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi everyone.
But the introductions don't stop
there, because people are
joining us through the magic
of the internet.
And in no particular order, if
you'd guys like to introduce
yourselves--
WOLFF DOBSON: I think
they should be in
display index order.
JENNY MURPHY: The display
index is different for
different people, though.
My display index order.
So the order on our screen that
we're looking at right
now, starting with
you, Abraham.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Hi, I'm
Abraham Williams.
I have a new startup
called Advocate.
I'm based in San Francisco, and
I've been exploring the
History API a lot recently.
And actually, on my YouTube
channel, there's an about an
hour presentation I gave at
I/O Hack last weekend if
anybody is interested
in learning more
about History API.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
And as far as my screen can
tell, next to you is Alan.
ALAN: Hey, guys.
JENNY MURPHY: Hi, Alan.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You're
muted, Alan.
JENNY MURPHY: And then just
joining us, Charles.
And a developer who just
commented on the post, and I
just invited--
I don't know how to--
I'm going to butcher
your name--
uh, Diwa?
DIWA: Yeah, hi.
You got it right.
JENNY MURPHY: Oh, awesome.
WOLFF DOBSON: Cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Continuing
along--
Fraser?
FRASER CAIN: Hi, everybody.
I'm Fraser Cain.
I'm the publisher of
Universe Today.
We'll be doing cool
hangouts with
telescopes here in Google+.
JENNY MURPHY: And definitely
last but not least, Gerwin.
GERWIN STURM: Yeah, hi.
I am Gerwin from Austria.
I'm developer of Hangout Comment
Tracker, and I'm
really looking forward
[INAUDIBLE] the new APIs, or
what I will do with them.
[INAUDIBLE]
JENNY MURPHY: Great.
Well, this show is about Google
I/O. It was a great
event, and a lot of you, a lot
of the people who are here
with us, actually attended the
event, or were involved in
some other way.
So I thought we'd just get
started by going around and
saying some of the things you
enjoyed about Google I/O, or
that you thought were pretty
cool that happened there.
CHARLES: It was nice to meet all
these people in real life,
for a change--
to meet Alan and Abraham
and Gerwin and you.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Or as we often call it, Hangout
In Real Life, or HIRL.
It was great to HIRL with
a bunch of you.
It was a great opportunity.
It was a lot of time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I like
the continued
verification of existence.
We're all real.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
We're not just elaborate
Google automatons.
Well, I am, but--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And the
developers, right?
There's real people out there
that are also not automatons--
automatons--
WOLFF DOBSON: I never thought
they were automatons.
That was only you.
CHARLES: Plus, I think if you
guys were automatons, you guys
would be more manga, anyways.
WOLFF DOBSON: Hey, I'm working
on combing my hair up, and
Jerry does have green hair,
and he has blue hair.
So I think we're pretty
freaking manga.
FRASER CAIN: Didn't you find
that a year of Google+ has
totally kind of changed your
interaction with the people
that use the Google products
and services?
I mean, a year ago, I didn't
know the names
of very many Googlers.
Now I probably know the name
of 20 people in Google.
So it's kind of thanks
to Google+, right?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That's cool.
You know, I've noticed that as
well, that when we were doing
developer relations prior to
Google+, it did seem like
there was a forum between
us and everyone.
And we still have the forum,
and it has a great use, but
now we can sit face-to-face
with people and talk about
developer issues in a really
casual setting, much like we
do when we travel
and do events.
And I think that's pretty cool,
to be able to do that so
casually and easily
whenever you want.
FRASER CAIN: I'll bet you that's
going to be one of the
unexpected benefits of this
for Google itself.
You guys weren't anticipating
this, but just how much direct
connection that people in Google
are going to have with
the people who use Google
services at various levels,
and how much relationships are
actually happening inside the
company and outside
the company.
Mark my words.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know,
right before we launched
Google+, we were dogfooding
hangouts all the time, for
example, and we had a pretty
good idea how big a deal this
was going to be.
I mean, all it took were a
couple drunk hangouts on a
Friday night to realize that
this is more than just another
feature, right?
This was something that was
really going to let us connect
with people.
The way it was allowing us to
connect with each other in
ways that we hadn't before.
WOLFF DOBSON: I think Google+
had the unexpected thing, at
least to me, that it really
helped us, because of the
circles and everything, sorted
some of my Google+ followers
and people I'm following into
interest categories.
So I now have a whole pile of
people who are comic artists,
and a whole pile of people
who are astronomers,
and things like that.
And so I can follow these
people, and learn about them,
and join hangouts with people I
don't know, but who turn out
to be really cool, rather
than just hanging out
with people I know.
Which I think is really fun.
Like you guys.
CHARLES: So in answer to your
question originally, what did
we all get out of I/O--
on the plane ride back,
I had all these ideas.
I think the thing that I got
most of it was I went to a
bunch of different sessions on
a bunch of different APIs,
ones that I had been using and
ones that I had been using
kind of peripherally, and I
spent a lot of time talking to
people, and I kind of got it
all mashed up in my head.
And on the plane ride home, I
realized that I had a couple
clients who could really, really
use a bunch of tools
that I'd been thinking about,
that we'd be discussing.
One in particular is a charity
that works in Zambia, and for
them, it's perfect fit of
connecting together all these
different free services
for them to reach
their audiences, and--
well, you guys know that we've
just gone through the
Kickstarter project,
so I'm all big on
raising funds right now.
So it was amazing to just have
all of those ideas in my head,
and I think being in a sling
and being unable to do much
actual detailed coding kept my
head up in the clouds and let
me see the big picture, which
was really, really handy.
I think Google has got so many
different tools that if
they're mated properly,
you can make some
really powerful stuff.
JENNY MURPHY: Very cool.
Well--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: If I
could just say--
I love that kind of experience
coming out of something like
Google I/O. Because I think
a lot of people go for the
sessions, which are History
API, or Hangout Apps, or
whatever it is.
But then it's that extra
experience you get at
something like Google I/O, when
everything sort of comes
together, or the conversations
that you have in the hallway,
I think really make it.
And one of the things that I
noticed at our Google+ booth
is that the office
hours were--
there were always people around
hanging out, asking
questions, and in those couches
we provide as well,
just sitting down, every once
in a while coding, or coming
up with new ideas for people.
Is that what you all experienced
as well?
GERWIN: Yeah, definitely.
So it's definitely a lot
different just to watch the
sessions on YouTube compared
to actually being there and
being able to talk to people
after the sessions and
comparing what you
experienced.
So it's just a totally different
feeling than just
attending the sessions.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, I ended up
spending the entire day in the
Sandbox just answering
questions.
Like I wasn't supposed to be
the entire time, but I just
was having so much fun talking
to people that were there just
hanging out.
And occasionally drawing
dinosaurs, but you know,
you've got to do that.
JENNY MURPHY: At least
we have to do that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, yeah, I was
going to say, G+ has to
have dinosaurs, or we don't
function correctly.
FRASER CAIN: So if you guys are
interested, I think one of
my astronomers has a live view
of this monster sunspot on the
sun right now.
So if you want, we could invite
him and sort of be in
the side of the hangout.
If you're interested.
Or I might have to drop
out and work with him.
But I just want to give
you that option.
JENNY MURPHY: Sure, that
that's definitely--
WOLFF DOBSON: I think having a
sunspot join our Hangout would
be pretty cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
I think we all agree
with that.
WOLFF DOBSON: Like, Hangouts are
sort of an international
phenomenon, and apparently
also an intersolar
phenomenon as well.
FRASER CAIN: All right.
I'll give him the link,
but I'll tell
him to come in muted.
So yeah.
Cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: We don't want
to hear a sunspot.
We just want to see it.
FRASER CAIN: I'll see
what I can do.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Awesome.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's
next, Jenny?
JENNY MURPHY: Well,
what's next?
Funny you should have mentioned
the History API just
a moment before.
WOLFF DOBSON: Oh my goodness!
Tell us more.
JENNY MURPHY: Because I
thought I'd take this
opportunity to talk a little
bit about one of the big
features we launched at Google
I/O, which we launched as a
developer preview, which is
called the history API.
So mind if I hold your
phone for a sec?
I just realized there's a prop
right here, Timothy's phone,
which he's never let
me hold before.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Don't
turn it on.
JENNY MURPHY: I won't.
It might explode.
But there's a really cool
Google+ feature that a lot of
people have used.
It's called Instant Upload.
And as you're at events,
you take a lot of
photos of your adventure.
And what's happening is in the
background, your phone is
uploading photos as you take
them to Google+, so that later
when you are back at home and
in the mood for sharing, you
have instantly accessible all
those photos that you took so
that you can share them with
the right audiences.
And the kind of philosophical
course of this is we've
separated out the burden of
creating the content and the
experiences you've had with the
sharing you do later on,
when you're in the right
mood for that.
And we thought this is a really
cool feature, and we
got a lot of great feedback from
people, so we decided to
expand it to include not just
photographs, but everything
that happens, all of those
little moments that make up
people using applications--
applications that you write.
And we also decided to open
it up to everyone.
So it's an open API for
application developers.
And that is the idea behind
the History API.
It is just entering
developer preview.
And what this means is that
it's not ready for release
into your products yet.
So your application, you can't
release it with the History
API yet, but you can start
banging on the API today to
experiment with how you'd use
it, and really importantly to
us, you can give us feedback for
how you want the API to be
when it's ready for production
release.
So it's a really good
opportunity for you as
application developers to have
a lot of influence on the
direction of an API as
we're developing it.
So we're very excited
about this.
So I am going to show you a
quick demo of the History API
in action through the magic
of screen sharing.
So let me switch the
cameras on over.
Actually, that one's already
toggled to me.
Switch screen sharing to my
web browser, make sure the
right window is up.
So here we have it.
This is a simple example
application that we created so
that you can start developing
right away.
It has another feature that's
part of the same developer
preview called the sign-in
button, which is really useful
for authenticating users.
It makes OAuth, which is a
really cool standard for
accessing data that your users
have created on Google, and it
makes the OAuth connection
process a whole lot easier.
So go ahead and hit the button,
and authentication
flow happens.
And then this sample application
has a bunch of
different activity types which
are used to represent the
different kinds of moments an
application could create, like
an application you're writing,
into moments that the History
API can understand.
So since it's just a bunch of
buttons in a panel, they
should probably be called push
button activity, but they're
just proxies for other kinds of
activities that could exist.
For example, right here in the
upper right is a button called
check-in activity that simulates
checking in with a
location-aware application.
So I hit the button, and I can
see API traffic down in the
little debugging panel.
And what's happened here is
this little JavaScript
application has pretended to
communicate a moment about me
checking in to the Googleplex,
which is actually accurate,
because it's where I actually
happen to be right now.
And we can see this moment
inserted into Google+.
So switching tabs over,
I can see our
plus.google.com/history, which
is a feature made available to
you as part of the developer
preview.
So you can see that the moments
have been inserted
into your Google+ history.
Here I can see the moment that I
just inserted with a picture
of me at an earlier time
checking in at some other
place in the Googleplex.
And the History API is about a
lot more than just check-ins.
There's a whole bunch of
different kinds of moments
that your application
can create.
You can use it to model moments
like when someone buys
something, like a book or a
movie or something like that,
when someone creates content,
like creates a blog post oa
tweet, when someone reviews a
restaurant, for example, and a
whole bunch of other stuff.
And for now we even have kind of
a catch-all activity called
Add Activity, which you can use
when no other activity is
appropriate for the kind of
action your user is taking in
your application.
And this list is one of
the big areas we're
interested in expanding.
So as you develop and play
around with this API, please
tell us what kinds of other
activities you think would
make the API more useful to you
and your application and
your users.
So--
ALAN: Jenny, what's the best
way to provide that kind of
feedback to you?
JENNY MURPHY: That's a
great question, Alan.
I was just about to show you.
So let me switch over to the
last half, where I'll show you
how to learn a little bit more
about the History API and how
to get feedback, like how to
tell us what kind of activity
types you might want.
So before I dig into the places
where you can send us
feedback, let me just show
you how you can sign up.
So if you go to developers.googl
e.com/+/history, you'll find all
the documentation on the
History API.
This includes that sample
project I just showed you.
You can download it and
start modifying it.
Reference docs, everything you
need to get started with the
developer preview.
And the top link in the left
side menu is to sign up for
the preview.
So what you'll do is you'll
come here and you'll enter
your email address into this
form, and we will add you to a
Google Group.
Being a member of that Google
Group will give you access to
the ability to create projects
that use this API.
It will allow you to submit
moments for your user, your
profile, and it will also
give you access to that
plus.google.com/history
beta UI I showed you
just a moment ago.
Once you're signed up, you can
download one of the projects
like the one I just demoed to
you and learn a whole bunch of
details about the API and the
different kinds of moments you
can send on our reference
docs.
And down at the bottom of our
reference docs is instructions
on how to request a new
type of moment.
We're using our issue
tracker for this--
and this is the same place
where you would submit
feedback on any other changes
or ideas you have for the
History API.
So you just click on over to
that and create a new issue,
and this is how you
would go ahead and
send us that feedback.
And that is History
API in a nutshell.
So let me kill the screen
sharing so we can
discuss it a bit.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do you all
have questions about the
History API?
Have you started using the
History API for anything in
particular?
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Well at I/O
Hack last weekend after Google
I/O, it was [INAUDIBLE]
sponsored by the GDGSF.
The weekend project I did there
was actually doing a
little app engine aggregator
that initially called in
GitHub activity, I Can Has
Cheezburger activity, Twitter
activity, and something else,
and it pushed that all onto
the History API.
Actually, it turned
out pretty cool.
I'm working on open
sourcing it.
I have to make it so
that secrets aren't
hard-coded and whatnot.
But it was pretty fun.
There was a couple of issues
like there was
conflicts with scopes--
you couldn't use any other
scopes with the History scope,
and so that kind of threw
a wrench in some of the
debugging, because if you wanted
to access somebody's
email address, then you couldn't
do that unless you
had them authorized twice.
But other than that, actually,
the developer experience was
pretty nice.
It was a little difficult
explaining it to some people,
because they'd be like, "so if I
put all my history in there,
then what can I do with it?" And
I'd be like, well, it's a
preview, so give Google
a little more time.
But other than that, it
was a lot of fun.
WOLFF DOBSON: We're working
on that part.
JENNY MURPHY: This is another
area where feedback from you
as you develop your
application is
really useful to us.
What are your visions for what
we can do with all that
information that's been loaded
into the history?
FRASER CAIN: Are people seeing
this as a way to get around
the no write access on the API,
to be able to queue up
things that they would want to
be able to then bring into
their feed?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It's important
not to think of this as a way
to get around it, but maybe
a better way to
do it, in most cases.
The problem with sort of a
write API is that then
developers might just push a
whole bunch of data into your
stream, and that's not really
good for the user that's
apparently producing that
content or the users that are
reading that content.
But with History, you can put
all sorts of data into this
private area, and then the user
can keep that just for
themselves, which you couldn't
get with just a basic write
API, and then they get to choose
what they do want to
share, and with who.
Which is a very Google+-y
way to do things.
It's that natural sharing that
we've been going on about for
a year now, where there's some
things I want to share with my
family, and some things I want
to share with my friends, and
there's some things I just
want to keep for myself.
FRASER CAIN: Right.
So you see it as a sort of--
over time, there will be a whole
bunch of these apps that
I will be connecting up
into the History API.
They will be dropping things
like photographs, videos, or
other pieces of data, songs I've
listened to, whatever,
and then I'll be able control
which of those actually get
pushed down into the feed, as
opposed to another site,
perhaps, that does it in a very
invasive, creepy way.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I think that
would be a way to put it, yes.
FRASER CAIN: That
would be ideal.
Yeah.
Perfect.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, before we
get to the next question, I
just want to take a moment to
ask the sun, how are you?
FRASER CAIN: So this is so
this is Chris Ridgeway,
who's-- you're in Indiana,
right, Chris?
CHRIS: Right.
FRASER CAIN: And so this is
actually a monster sunspot
that's currently on
the sun right now.
Man, what's its number?
A--
CHRIS: AR1520.
FRASER CAIN: AR1520, which is
actually one of the largest
sunspots that's been on the
surface of the sun in a couple
of years now.
And it's actually just rotating
to perhaps shoot a
flare or two off at the earth.
So we might get some auroras at
pretty southern latitudes.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, well, let's
keep an eye on that!
WOLFF DOBSON: If it happens to
do that during the hangout,
that would be pretty cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
would be OK.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah,
unfortunately, I don't think
Chris has the right filters
on his scope to be
able to detect it.
You'd need an x-ray
telescope working.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I'm learning
so much just by staring at
these blurry spots.
Why do they appear blurry?
Can I just ask that one
astronomy question of you?
FRASER CAIN: Why do the sunspots
appear blurry?
Well, you're seeing the sun
through the atmosphere, and
you're seeing the atmosphere
kind of
wobbling back and forth.
And so that's why you're seeing
things kind of blurred.
It's video of the sun seen
through the atmosphere, and
the atmosphere distorts
the sun.
The sunspots themselves are
actually-- they're still
super-hot, they're still 5000
degrees Kelvin, but they're a
little cooler than the rest
of the sun, and that's why
they're are a little
bit darker.
And they're actually the points
of the solar atmosphere
where the magnetic field lines
from inside the sun are poking
outside of the sun, and so
usually there's matched pairs
where these magnetic field lines
are piercing the surface
of the sun and coming
back down.
And what happens is these lines
will get all twisted up
and tangled, and then they kind
of snap, and that's when
we get these flares that come
off the surface of the sun.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well,
OK, then.
FRASER CAIN: There you go.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you so
much for that explanation.
I really appreciate it.
ALAN: I think it's the first
time I've ever had that
properly explained to me.
FRASER CAIN: So this is what
we do every Sunday night.
This is our virtual star party,
so I thought I'd give
you guys a--
WOLFF DOBSON: No, this
is totally awesome.
We should invite the sun
to all of our Hangouts.
FRASER CAIN: Well, sometimes
it has to
be the moon or Saturn.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: I would be
fine with a different
celestial body every week.
WOLFF DOBSON: Not
Pluto, though.
That guy has fallen off.
JENNY MURPHY: We'd need a really
powerful [INAUDIBLE].
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hey, if we're
going to accept the moon, we
have to accept Pluto every
once in a while.
WOLFF DOBSON: No.
He used to be cool--
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: I think
this is a feature
request for Google Fx.
WOLFF DOBSON: Is to add Pluto?
We need to have a telescope
strong enough
to see Pluto clearly.
We'll work on that.
FRASER CAIN: We could do that.
WOLFF DOBSON: All right.
So before we move onto the
next thing, any other
questions and comments about
the History API?
CHARLES: Yeah, I've got
two quick questions.
The first is kind of
directed at Wolff.
During the code lab there, we
were having some problems
getting History working
with Hangouts.
Is there any further word
on that [INAUDIBLE]?
WOLFF DOBSON: The issue that
Abraham was talking about
earlier was with the scopes, the
History scope not getting
along with the other scopes.
That's a broad problem with
all the Hangout--
Hangout scopes are just other
scopes, so that was the
disagreement that was
happening there.
So I think when that issue's
cleared up, the Hangouts will
get resolved as well.
I don't know what the
ETA is on that.
JENNY MURPHY: It's one of our
top priorities right now, so.
WOLFF DOBSON: That's
what I'm saying.
So yeah, it was a specific case
of a generic problem.
CHARLES: OK.
The second is a question that
I've been asked a couple of
times now--
if pages will be able to add to
their own history, and will
there be a way to do that as
part of the developer preview?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: It is not
available now, and the preview
is on right now, so I don't
think you'd expect that any
time terribly soon.
But yeah, it's a question that
was asked at Google I/O, and
we've been thinking about
it, but we don't have an
answer right now.
CHARLES: That would be really
useful to have.
FRASER CAIN: Do you have any
plans for any differences
between the history
between personal
pages and brand pages?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So I think
that's sort of the same
question, and at the end of the
day, where it is right now
is Google+ History is available
for profiles, and
it's not available for
Google+ pages.
And there's a number of both
technical and conceptual
issues to sort out before we
would make any other change
there, and as I understand it,
the product team doesn't have
anything to announce yet.
JENNY MURPHY: So before we move
on to the next thing,
does anyone have any
other comments or
questions about history?
Great.
OK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: What's
the next thing?
JENNY MURPHY: Well,
the next thing--
I see that Diwa has been
patiently waiting.
You commented on the
announcement post mentioning
you had a question, which we'll
do our best to answer.
DIWA: Well, you guys
seem so advanced.
I'm just a newbie web programmer
probably boring you
to [INAUDIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Well, what's
your question?
DIWA: Can you hear me?
JENNY MURPHY: Yes, we can
hear you loud and clear.
DIWA: So I'm just starting
out with my web
app, which uses Google+.
And one of the things I'm trying
to figure out is, is
there a difference in using the
Google's own client for
Ruby versus Omnia?
I'm not sure what the
difference is.
JENNY MURPHY: I'm not all that
familiar with Omnia.
But we produce client libraries
for several
languages that we strongly
recommend you use, because we
have a lot more control over
them, so we can put more
effort into making sure that
they are very compatible with
our APIs, especially as our
APIs change and new
features come out.
Which could, for example,
provide performance
enhancements, integrate that
into our API client libraries
much faster than a lot
of third parties
might be able to.
So all that being said, all of
our APIs are restful web
services and use other internet
standards, like
OAuthentication.
And that means that you can use
the endpoints directly if
you wish, if you have a strong
reason to, or if there's
another client library that just
makes more sense for your
application for whatever
reason-- maybe it integrates
better with some other
frameworks you use, or
something like that-- you
are welcome to go
ahead and use them.
Just be aware that they may not
be as performant, they may
not take advantage of all the
advanced features we have,
like for example etags,
or they may not
respect cache headers.
And also, it's a little bit
more difficult for us to
support you if you're using a
client library that we're not
as familiar with.
So I would take a look at the
features of both, and just see
the one that's better for
your application.
And if in doubt, use
our library,
especially the Ruby one.
It's really cool.
Right, Wolff?
WOLFF DOBSON: Definitely.
I like the Ruby library.
I'm not just a developer.
I'm also a client.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Wolff and I both have
spent some time
in that client library.
DIWA: Thanks.
The second question I had is
that if I'm trying to store
the refresh tokens in my local
database, the [INAUDIBLE]
decided which would be better to
index it by, or would they
email the user or the Google+
handle or the ID.
Do you guys have any
input on that?
JENNY MURPHY: That's another
really good question.
What is the unique identifier
of the person?
And we recommend that you use
the numeric profile ID.
WOLFF DOBSON: Although you
should not assume that it will
stay a 20-digit number or
whatever it is right now.
That is, the IDs are strings,
and you should
treat them as strings.
JENNY MURPHY: Very specifically,
you'll notice
that the current numeric ID is
just slightly too large to fit
in a lot of integer
representations, so it may
unexpectedly overflow those
representations today.
So treat it as a string, please,
an opaque string.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yes.
Absolutely as a string.
DIWA: Thanks.
JENNY MURPHY: You're welcome.
Those are some great
questions.
WOLFF DOBSON: OK.
So let's talk about Hangouts.
So we were featuring a whole new
set of apps that came out
near or around I/O. The ones we
talked about in the session
with the Google Art project,
which we're
really excited about--
it's all of these beautiful,
high-res scans
of worldwide art--
famous paintings, nearly famous
paintings, paintings
that should be famous,
sculpture, all that stuff, all
in a way that you can actually
hunt through our database,
share it with friends, and you
can go on virtual tours with
each other.
So you really have a shared
museum experience while you're
in a hangout.
And we're looking forward to
people coming up with fun
things to do with that.
I had a lot of fun coming up
with amusing keywords to send
into it to see what I
can come up with.
I particularly liked--
"Pirate Isle" turns out to have
a really cool bunch of
pirates left over from some
old painting, which
I thought was neat.
But some of the detail on some
of the scans is ridiculous.
You can get all the way in and
see individual brushstrokes.
And with the hangout
functionally, we actually have
the ability to drag other people
into that same level of
detail and look at the
same pieces of
information at the same time.
Really excited about it.
We also had "Story Before Bed,"
which is great if you're
talking to kids.
And one of my favorites is the
mini-clip 8-Ball Pool, which
turns out to be really fun.
We got together and played a
whole bunch of games right
before it launched, and we had a
lot of people playing all at
the same time.
And one of the things that was
neat is that the audio from
the game was actually leaking
into the Hangout, so it sort
of felt like you were actually
in a pool hall.
You could hear all the balls
clicking against each other
and everything.
It was an unexpected benefit
that we really liked.
It's a very tight game.
It's a lot of fun.
You should try it.
And we also have a couple other
apps, like Symphonical
and Panoramio.
There was a lot of
excitement--
we actually our partners there,
Goko, who had Dominion
in a hangout.
And those of you who are gamers
know that Dominion is a
very popular card game.
Maybe a little nerdy, but.
But it's an amazingly fun game,
and we're really looking
forward to seeing that out.
But it was playable I/O, and
there's a screen shot.
It was reshared widely.
It was neat.
It's cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: That
integration was
really neat to see.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
They have a lot of fun little
details, like when you buy
certain things, they actually
have overlays that appear on
you while you're doing it.
So if you buy gold, you
get little gold
coins over your eyes.
If you buy Jack-of-all-trades,
you get this big hat and
everything.
And the funny thing about that
is, not only is it fun just to
see the things, but it's
actually really useful.
Because you can kind of, while
people are playing, especially
if you turn the animation speed
up because you know how
to play the game, you actually
track people by what they're
buying by looking at their
faces as they're playing.
Really fun.
And we had our code lab, and
the code lab is neat.
Some of you were there.
It addressed the thing that I
felt was very important about
when you're watching, like,
space fiction, which is that
whenever the two ships kind of
arrive in space and one of
them says, "Onscreen!" and
it shows the other guy--
they're in a hangout at
that very minute.
They're actually talking
to each other.
And so I wanted to have people
build the software that you
would need on a bridge of a ship
to have everybody talk to
each other.
So that was the goal.
It's neat.
We're hopefully going to get
it up for everybody at some
point in the future.
So yeah.
That was Hangouts at I/O.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Do we
have questions,
comments about that?
WOLFF DOBSON: Questions,
comments from
our friends in Hangouts?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: All questions
on Hangouts have
already been addressed.
WOLFF DOBSON: Well, a lot
of them were there.
We answered a lot
of questions.
ALAN: I'm still amazed
by the sunspot.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, it's
pretty awesome.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah, that was
definitely an accomplishment
[INAUDIBLE], having been in a
Hangout with a celestial body.
WOLFF DOBSON: I was going
to say, with a star.
JENNY MURPHY: With a star.
It's a really big thing
to have at a Hangout.
ALAN: A real star.
I think I need to save this
moment to my History.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And
full circle.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Well, we have a few moments
left, so I thought I'd address
some of the questions that I'm
seeing on the comments thread.
So Sid asks, "Is there any
desire for History to work
with Gmail in the future?
We already have Google
Account Reports.
What is the anticipated
integration going to look
like?"
And this is an example of some
of the constant feedback we're
interested in hearing.
So in addition to the feedback
about how you as a developer
would like to integrate with the
History API, we would also
very much like to hear how you
think we should use the
history API internally to
communicate between other
different applications that
you use at Google.
So just tell us what you
think it would be like,
and just let us know.
If you were here you could tell
us in person right now,
but maybe next time.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: + mentions and
forum comments are a great way
to get that information to us.
We'll see that.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Let me look at the thread.
I don't see any other questions
that are that
developer-y on the
thread right now.
So does anybody have any final
thoughts before we wrap it up
for the week?
FRASER CAIN: I've got a couple
of quick questions, one, I
guess, for Gerwin, or for
Gerwin's sake, which is, right
now Gerwin's comment tracker
doesn't work with events.
And so--
GERWIN: Oh, it does now.
FRASER CAIN: It does now?
Never mind.
It does now.
WOLFF DOBSON: Gerwin's
all over that.
FRASER CAIN: OK.
And then, I've been getting a
lot of people complaining from
other countries, certain
European countries, that they
can't partake in our
live events.
Any sort of information
I can give them?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So you're asking
about release timelines
globally for products
features.
FRASER CAIN: No.
People in Germany can't access
Hangouts on Air.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
That's what I said, isn't it?
I don't know.
Nobody at this table,
I don't--
unless, you guys correct me--
knows when those things
might be launched.
WOLFF DOBSON: "I don't
know" is the correct
answer for this question.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: In general,
we, especially as DevRel,
don't comment on future
releases.
And so the point at which
Product is ready to announce
anything is when they'll
let us know.
And of course, we understand
that that's a concern, and
have communicated that
to the team.
FRASER CAIN: No workarounds?
All right.
ALAN: My big question I asked
when I was noticed there is
the History, the moment seemed
really great for HIRL for us
in our app.
Because it's a gaming app, we
want to screen capture moments
inside the Hangout.
So we could use HTML5 to grab
most of the DOM, but we can't
grab the video or the thumbnail
or the film strip,
which is really the key.
And for us, it's the moment
where somebody really blows a
role, or somebody really
succeeds [INAUDIBLE]--
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah, you want
the reaction face.
ALAN: Yeah.
And we want that stuff to get
caught, because you can't
catch that manually.
But those are the
moments, right?
Those are the moments.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
That's excellent feedback.
Again, that's a future-looking
sort of thing.
But yeah, capturing moments
in Hangouts--
that would be cool.
JENNY MURPHY: Yeah.
Especially the [INAUDIBLE]
moment.
That would be pretty cool.
WOLFF DOBSON: In the foosball
game that one of the agencies
made, they had, every time
somebody scored, they actually
popped up an overlay that was
the person who had just been
scored on, so you could see
their face going, "aw!" Which
was, again, surprisingly fun.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: You could
almost build that in
automatically, like roller
coasters, when you go past a
certain point on the roller
coaster and it catches a
picture of everybody--
every time a bad die
rolls, you just
automatically get a picture.
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
You begin screenshotting as
soon as that happens.
ALAN: Yeah.
Most games could
programmatically predict the moments.
ABRAHAM WILLIAMS: Yeah.
When all the sad faces
are going to happen.
WOLFF DOBSON: Absolutely.
It has to watch the chat
and everything.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
That's a great idea.
WOLFF DOBSON: Actually, many
years ago, there was an MIT
Media Lab project where they had
a thing that would capture
30 seconds of video whenever
your heart rate went up.
And so the example video they
had was this woman hunched
over this computer, and this
guy comes up behind her and
goes, "Boo!" And you
can see the video
of her looking surprised.
JENNY MURPHY: Pretty cool.
The possibilities are endless
with biometric integration
into hangouts and History.
FRASER CAIN: I had one more
question, but I get the
feeling that all my questions
were answered by all the
people that were actually
at I/O.
ALAN: Next period you've
got to come to I/O.
FRASER CAIN: Yeah, clearly.
But like right now, I'm only
able to run one hangout app at
a time, right?
WOLFF DOBSON: That's
not entirely true.
You can run an extension in a
hangout app at the same time.
FRASER CAIN: Yes, yes.
One of each.
Is there any plans to figure
out a way that I
could not do that?
Or do more?
How can I have the lower third
and the comment tracker?
That's [INAUDIBLE].
WOLFF DOBSON: Yeah.
The answer to that is that--
I just lost my microphone.
The answer is, I'm
so surprised my
microphone fell out.
JENNY MURPHY: Unfortunately
we're running out of time, so
we'll answer this
pretty briefly.
Again, this is a
future feature.
We can't really talk a lot, or
we can't really comment on it,
because we don't know.
FRASER CAIN: You're aware it's
an issue that multiple apps
and extensions at the same time
will create a very rich
video experience?
JENNY MURPHY: Exactly.
WOLFF DOBSON: Multiple
extensions.
JENNY MURPHY: And we think
it would be really cool.
There's a lot of issues we'd
have to overcome to get
something like that
implemented.
It's on our radar.
We think it would be cool, and
that's all I really have to
say about that.
So we are actually completely
out of time.
WOLFF DOBSON: We're
being waved at.
Time is up.
JENNY MURPHY: So we are going
to be leaving you now.
WOLFF DOBSON: Thanks so much
for coming, everybody.
JENNY MURPHY: Yes.
Thanks a lot for joining us for
this week's session of the
Google+ Platform Office Hours.
Bye everyone!
WOLFF DOBSON: Bye!
ALAN: Bye.